welcome back to cbs morning's a
bombshell lawsuit accuses the nfl of
racism in hiring coaches and we have the
first interview with a former head coach
who has filed it his name is brian
flores he was fired last month after
three years coaching the miami dolphins
his lawsuit claims the nfl has failed to
create a fairer hiring process quote
nothing has changed in fact the racial
discrimination has only been made worse
by the nfl's disingenuous commitment to
social equity as of today there are
three head coaches of color including
one black man out of 32 in the league
that's down from eight in 2018. about 70
percent of the players are black the nfl
says in a statement diversity is core to
everything we do and there are a few
issues on which our clubs and our
internal leadership team spend more time
we will defend against these claims
which are without merit brian flores is
here with us right now with his
attorneys doug woodard and john
aleftarakis make sure i got that right
for an interview you'll see first on cbs
mornings good morning um we appreciate
you guys joining us we know that you
guys did reach out to us last week but
i'm glad you guys are sitting down with
us now brian i'll start with you last
week you interviewed for the head
coaching job for the new york giants
what happened leading up to that
interview
before we get into that i just want to
say thank you to uh you know i've
received a lot of uh
calls emails text messages
in support of what's going on it's been
a tough uh 24 hours i would say um
so to everyone who's uh reached out um
obviously family and uh
i just want to say thank you of course i
just want to say thank you so last week
um i interviewed for the giants position
um
i was set to interview on thursday the
the monday prior uh before before i
interviewed i received the text message
from bill belichick saying
congratulations on the giant space
essentially congratulations on the
giants job um
uh it was a little bit of back and forth
um we have the text messages there on
the screen yeah there was some back and
forth and some confusion because yeah
you haven't sat down with the giants yet
i have not sat down with the giants of
some back and forth and i just uh i
asked him is this you talking to the
right brian um and uh as you you've seen
them through the text messages he was
actually uh
thought he was texting brian dabo who
they ended up hiring yes sir so at that
point
how did that make you feel knowing that
you were walking into an interview
where a decision might have already been
made it was a range of emotions uh
humiliation
uh
uh disbelief um
anger um
now i've worked so hard to get to to
um
to where i am from
football to become a head coach um
put 18 years in in this league and it
was uh
to to
to go on what was going to be a what
what felt like or what was a sham
interview i was uh i was hurt but you
went knowing that you probably weren't
going to get it why did you continue to
go uh
i think uh
i i
there's still hope maybe it's called it
called the audacity of hope um
and uh i was
i have a belief that you know there's
good in people i i just do um we knew he
wasn't getting that job on the day
before that that giants interview we we
reached out to you cbs to to to all of
you to yeah to start talking about doing
this interview today because we knew he
wasn't getting the job we knew it was a
setup we knew they were just trying to
comply with the rooney rule we started
drafting the complaint and and here we
are the giants say they are pleased and
confident in the hiring process
i get the sense from the lawsuit from
you right now that you had a feeling
like here we go again this wasn't the
first time you felt discriminated
against in the league yeah yeah i mean
i've
i mean the ruling the rooney rules
intended to
uh you know give minorities an
opportunity to sit down in front of
ownership but i think what it's turned
into is um
an instance where guys are just checking
the box um and that's been the case i've
been on some interviews in the past that
um
where that's i've had that feeling
there's always no way to
to know for sure but um
but you know and i know i know i know
i'm not alone to have the rooney rule i
think that's not even that even isn't
that a problem what are we gonna say
it's it's absolutely i'm sorry it's
absolutely a problem and one of the
things that we're doing to help
effectuate this change is you know the
rooney rule's tied to the assumption
that
presidents owners are going to do the
right thing hire the best most qualified
candidate yeah what we want to do is tie
you know certain things to performance
and action through this but brian the
reason i i the timing is really
important here because you're actually
up for two additional nfl jobs right now
yeah so
why why did you do this knowing from
your own statement that you may have
sacrificed your future in the nfl and
you're a young man yeah well i i mean i
i let both the teams know that you know
we're gonna we're gonna file but
look i love coaching you know i'm gifted
to coach i know that um
and the relationships i've built with
players coaches support staff i'm gifted
to coach and i love coaching i want to
coach um and i've heard some reliable
sources you're very good coach
always room for improvement but
i like to think that as well um but this
is bigger than coaching of course this
is much bigger than coaching now we'll
get back to the lawsuit um in regards to
the broncos and the giants but i want to
talk about the miami dolphins for a
second um you make claims that you were
offered 100 000
for each game this team lose um
subsequently uh to get a better draft
pick um
kind of speak on that because you don't
hear about that going on behind closed
doors
i'm a former player
i know you as a coach you want to win i
walk in that locker room i want to win
i don't hear
people from the front office and above
making those type of decisions that can
change the outcome of your coaching
career
uh yeah uh look this game's done a lot
for me um i grew up not far from here in
the projects in brownsville brooklyn um
i didn't grow up with a lot and this
game you know changed my life uh so to
attack the integrity of the game that's
that's what i felt was happening in that
instance and um i wouldn't stand for it
and that was dolphins owner stephen ross
yes
yes
so and you think it hurt your career i
think i think it hurt my standing with
within the organization um and
ultimately was the reason why i was let
go well word on the street now though
brian is that either you've torpedoed
your career that this is the craziest
thing you could have done or that it's
very brave and very bold of you to do
how are you feeling are you at peace
with your decision and was this a very
difficult decision for you to make to
file a lawsuit before you have a job uh
uh
i understand the risks
and yes it was a difficult decision and
i went back and forth
and like i said i i love coaching i do
it's something that
i'm passionate about it brings me joy
and i love
helping young people reach their
potential and become the best versions
of themselves i'm gifted to do that
brian but this is bigger than than that
i mean can i just say in 2022 the fact
that we don't have one black owner we
only have one black head coach that's
actually one you know
really brian needs to be applauded for
stepping forward to be the first person
to really contest it it's been talked
about well you know but that but now he
has stepped forward to challenge it
you've heard the statement from the nfl
in a statement diversity is core to
everything we do there are a few issues
on which our clubs and our
internal teams spend more time on
they've acknowledged their problems you
know the executives there have
acknowledged their problems now their
the pr team is trying to spin something
you know they could take two different
paths they could they could take the
path of trying to defend and litigate or
we hope that they take the path of
actually trying to correct things to be
an example not only for the nfl but for
american society
when you talk about the owners you know
you got 31 white billionaires and then
the packers have a special situation 70
about of the players are are black uh
there's a power dynamic that's visible
there yeah in the lawsuit there's this
explosive line that the nfl has managed
much like a plantation that's a direct
quote
why did you decide to settle on that
metaphor
uh
i just think i i think uh look we didn't
we didn't have to file a lawsuit for for
the world to know that there's a problem
from a from a hiring standpoint in
regards to minority coaches in the
national football league the numbers
speak for themselves right we filed a
lawsuit um so that we could create some
change um and that's important to me i
think we're at a fork in the road right
now you know we're either going to keep
it the way it is
or we're going to go in another
direction and actually make some real
change where um
we're actually changing the hearts and
minds of those who make decisions to
hire uh head coaches um executives et
cetera and that's where we got to get we
got to change hearts brian i heard
someone say but don't companies or clubs
have the right to hire the person they
think is the best qualified for the job
or the person they feel is right for
them whatever race they are whatever
race they are yes
they do you know uh and and that's
that's that's very reasonable to me but
at the same time uh
there are i know a very a lot of very
capable coaches executives uh
minorities uh coaches executives who are
minorities um
and in a lot of cases are
um as qualified um
more qualified and quite frankly better
than than their white counterparts
the difference here the opportunity they
are given an equal opportunity exactly
and you know when we talk about this
fork in the road that the nfl has and
gail you talked about the statement that
they released
denying and saying that they're going to
defend what was absent from their
response to this 60-page complaint with
serious allegations from a decorated
head coach is how about we'll
investigate we're troubled by this we'll
look into it immediate you know no
denial disregard disregard and defend
the point about the companies have the
right to hire who they think is best
qualified i we all agree with that but
the difference here if what you're
saying is true and you seem to have
receipts they knew ahead of time that
you weren't going to get the job so i'm
thinking why waste your time and theirs
and the word minority is is it's loaded
because there's different connotations
we might be marginalized in certain
areas but our contributions to this game
both on the field and outside of the
lines are immense and when you have
quality coaches that are available that
are gifted and can lead teams but not
getting the opportunity that's why you
are standing for what you're standing
for um but i want you to have one last
one those are called facts that's right
one last thing i'll let you say this but
you still want to coach in this league i
absolutely want to coach in this league
but i also know that this isn't
i'm not the only story here yeah i'm not
the only one with a story today you're
speaking up for decades of this going on
this is hopefully stopping you from
happening this is you know there are
people have come before me and and and
um i know there are others who who have
who have similar stories and um
it's hard to speak out um it is you know
you're giving up you're making some
sacrifices but um
this is again this is bigger than
football this is bigger than coaching
thank you for using your voice you're
doing the right thing thank you uh
welcome back to cbs mornings uh we just
had a big roundtable interview with
brian flores his two lawyers on this
explosive lawsuit against the nfl uh and
two teams three teams actually uh
one of those teams the giants uh i
wanted to give people a bigger picture
their more complete statement here okay
they say they are pleased and confident
in their hiring process they also say
in the conversation to be our head coach
that brian flores was in the
conversation to be our head coach until
the 11th hour
ultimately we hired the individual we
felt was most qualified
close quote be our next head coach
all right we just wanted to make we just
wanted to be on the record we wanted to
be clear there and the dolphins also had
a statement regarding the allegation
that they were essentially trying to fix
losses yeah the dolphins also had a
statement we are aware of the lawsuit
through the media reports that came out
this afternoon we vehemently deny any
allegations of racial discrimination and
are proud of the diversity and inclusion
throughout our organization
the implication we acted in a manner
inconsistent with the integrity of the
game is incorrect we will be withholding
further comment on the lawsuit at this
time
so you characterize the nfl but here's
the the teams weighing in as well as as
we allow brian flores and his lawyers um
to make these claims we want to make
sure that we read the statements from
these organizations in the nfl as we did
when we sat down absolutely and when we
were talking with brian and his lawyers
everybody has a statement but their
bottom line was actions speak louder
than words let's see what happens no
doubt